What about
the legal
battle between Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and Disney?
You said you would happily
welcome Disney to South Carolina
if they wanted to move.
What do you think of Governor
DeSantis, his leadership
when it comes to the back
and forth with Disney?
Well, it's
the hypocrisy of the whole thing.
What I said was,
first of all, this all started with
the don't say gay bill, right.
And it basically said
you couldn't
talk about
gender to any child
before the third grade.
I have been on record saying,
I don't think that went far enough.
They should not be talking to our kids
about gender, period.
That's what parents
talk to their kids about.
Not in school
So let's put that bill away
and put that to the side.
I totally agree with the bill
and think that it needed to go further.
And I think they've done that since then.
What I'm talking about
is the fact that here
you have a woke company,
even woke for years.
I remember when Disney went after
President Trump for immigration.
This is nothing new.
So here you have DeSantis,
who accepted 50,000
political contributions from Disney
He went and put their executives
and their lobbyists
on prominent boards throughout Florida,
and he went
and basically
gave the highest corporate
subsidies in Florida history to Disney.
But because they went and criticized him,
now he's going to spend
taxpayer dollars on a lawsuit
It's just like all this vendetta stuff.
We've been down that road again.
We can't go down that.
Businesses were my partners
in South Carolina.
We didn't always get along.
And I
you know,
luckily South Carolina's very anti woke.
But when you have a company like that,
don't bring the citizens
taxpayer dollars into it.
Pick up the phone,
deal with it, settle it
the way you should.
And I just think he's being hypocritical.
And publican
and presidential
hopeful
Nikki Haley
drawing a clear distinction
from her main
rivals,
Donald Trump and Governor Ron
DeSantis during a CNN town hall.
Joining us now,
CNN senior political commentator
Scott Jennings
and CNN political commentator
and attorney Bakari Sellers.
Good morning. Welcome to you both.
I think let's just start
with coming off of that town hall.
I mean,
how do you do from your perspective?
Was it a good night for her?
I thought she's a very
polished presentation.
You know, she may be the most polished
politician in the field.
The question is,
is that what people are looking for?
That is the question these days.
And, you know, she
she had some great moments on Russia.
I think I like some of the honesty
she had on a few issues.
She does engage
in a lot of the normal political pablum
that sort of is out of vogue right now
in the Trump era.
But overall,
I thought it was a pretty good night.
She passed the test
and we'll see if that makes a difference
in her polling car.
You know,
Nikki Haley, I mean, you have
you were in elected office
at the same time.
I mean, is this a stand
beside each other?
Not at the same desk,
but beside each other
for about four years.
And we're from the same home county.
So shout out to Bamberg County, where
we're punching above our weight
this morning.
But Nikki Haley, I'd say this to vote
for a long period of time.
She's probably the most talented
politician in the country.
I say that with no hesitation.
She's very skilled.
She's very good.
One on
one in these small retail settings,
which is going to bode
well in places
like Iowa and New Hampshire
and even back at home in South Carolina.
The problem that Nikki
Haley has is
nobody really knows what she stands for
and I'm not sure
she clarified that last night.
You saw many of the inconsistencies.
And sometimes politicians,
including myself,
we try to get too cute by half
and we begin to weave in and weave out.
And sometimes we just make no sense.
You saw that on things
like abortion
where she didn't
want to be nailed down,
where she signed a 20 week abortion
bill in South Carolina,
with the exception for life of the mother
but no exception for rape and incest.
She didn't really want to talk about that
last night.
She didn't want to talk about
whether or not she would sign
her successor six week abortion plan.
So when you think about these things,
you see it was a little bit uneven.
She was extremely strong
to Scott's
point on issues that she knows
really well on Afghanistan,
on Russia, on foreign policy.
When she got in, woke ism
and the cultural politics of the day,
you saw she was really uncomfortable.
Let's play
what she said
about Ukraine
and Western support for Ukraine.
And then compare it
to what one of her rivals.
Vivek Ramaswamy,
another Republican candidate,
had to say about
what he thinks we should do.
Vis-a-vis funding Ukraine.
Here they were both yesterday
Ukraine has the
ability to win,
but we have to think bigger than that.
And for them to sit there
and say that
this is a territorial dispute
that's just not the case.
To say that we should stay neutral.
It is in the best interests of America.
It's in the best interests
of our national security
for Ukraine to win.
We have to see this through.
We have to finish it.
I do not think it is
a top foreign policy priority for us.
I don't think it is preferable for Russia
to be able to invade a sovereign country
that it's its neighbor
But I think the job of the US
president is to look
after American interests.
Not only did
she distinguish herself from him,
she distinguish herself on this issue
from Donald Trump.
And from at least
where Ron DeSantis was
when Tucker Carlson asked him about it.
Yeah, it's
a clear eyed position
about the need
for the United States
to help the Ukrainians repel
this Russian invasion.
What we didn't play for Ramaswamy
is he went further.
He said We have to end the war
by making major concession
territory to the Russians,
which is I mean, this is like
you know,
sort of pathetic dorm room debater crap.
She had a real clear
eyed position
about what's in the best interests and
and whether this position is the
biggest issue in the primary or not.
The fact that someone is saying it out
loud and making the case
to the American people, like,
we got to win this thing.
That is a good thing.
And I'm glad she did that.
She was very clear.
She was very good.
The problem
that Nikki Haley is going to have is that
is the Republican Party
where she is right now
because she sounded
a lot like Lindsey Graham.
She sounded a lot like George W Bush.
They just elected Donald Trump,
which is the antithesis to everybody
I just named.
And so Ron DeSantis
is going to have his lunch eaten by Nikki
Haley and Donald Trump
on that stage
on the issue of foreign policy.
He just does not have the depth.
You saw it in the Tucker
Carlson interview.
But Nikki Haley did show she can debate.
I think the problem is
where is the majority
of maybe not Republicans,
but the Republican voting base?
I think that's interesting
because as you pointed out, Bakari,
leaning into foreign policy
and her strength there
because of her time,
of course, with the U.N.,
is that a top issue
for Republican voters?
I think it's
just still a word from Scott last night.
It's it's more of just like
this.
This whole thing is
just floating on vibes
to steal the word again. It really is.
They want a fighter.
They want somebody who's going
to feel like they're in the ring.
They're fighting for them.
I don't think they want
someone who is an X's and O's policy wonk
who is a fighter.
Chris Christie.
Well, I was trying to see that.
I usually don't bury the lead.
I don't you
know, Chris
Christie is going to be somebody
and I personally have
a conspiracy theory.
I think Chris Christie has one job
in this primary
which is to take out Donald Trump.
I think donors got together
and said, you go do your Marco
Rubio thing to Donald Trump.
So we shall see.
I think Nikki Haley will be able
to stand the test of time.
But I just don't think it's her time.
I.
So there is a
I guess that it might not be
what most voters are focused on,
but a real issue with entitlements
and funding Social Security and Medicare.
And I think Jake did a really good job
last night
asking her about her plan
because she has been one
who said younger folks in their twenties
can't be guaranteed to retire
at whatever age we're at now.
What are we at? 64 so far away from that?
I don't know. You're closer
to this because this is where Jake Astor.
At what age what is your plan
to get this back on track?
Here's the exchange
Time for some honesty from Nikki Haley.
If the retirement age is 66
or 67 right now.
What are you talking about
raising it to
for the people in their twenties?
We have to go.
We'd have to do the calculations.
We'd have to figure out.
And I am an accountant and
and you know what accountants do?
Accountants do their homework
and they make sure that
when they do something they do it
right or they don't do it.
So I'm not going to give you a
false time.
The crowd applauded,
but it was not an answer.
Yeah, it was a little bit
of a of a dodge.
And I do like the fact
that she's being honest about it.
You know,
one thing about Trump and DeSantis on
this issue
is they're trying to appeal to all these
new Republicans
who you may recognize
because they were Bill
Clinton's voters in the 1990s.
We now sound like Democrats
from the nineties on entitlements.
This is like,
we're not going to touch it.
We'll never touch it.
There's nothing wrong.
Let's bury our head in the sand.
That's not really a legitimate position
because as she said last night,
it is going bankrupt
if we don't do something.
So I like the honesty on the problem.
I would like to see more specificity
but this is not the issue
that's going to decide.
What about the issue of.
I want to play for you very quickly.
That of course, came up last night
as well.
We'll hear what she said and
talk about on the other side
you had to define Woke.
There's a lot of things.
I mean, you want to start
with biological boys
playing in girls sports.
That's one thing.
The fact that we have gender
pronoun classes in the military now,
I mean, all of these things
that are pushing
what a small minority
want on the majority of Americans,
it's too much
or you want it.
You wouldn't take that.
I was going to say,
this is your favorite topic.
No, it's not.
But the silence was just palpable.
I appreciated that. No.
First of all,
that's not the definition of woke.
Woke has been co-opted
by a lot of white
folk, a lot of conservatives debased
and then used to my memory Friday.
So it's used to mean anything that's
that's not white that's not straight.
And so so that's just not what it is.
And you hear
people talk about things
like cultural Marxism.
That's not the root of the word.
In fact,
the word started in 1920
for most of America
so that they understand
it was about black folk
talking about other black folks
saying stay woke
when you're in Mississippi or Alabama,
stay woke politically,
stay woke philosophically,
that is what the word means now
to take it
and make it mean something
and to base it that it does not.
And you saw her last night.
She was stumbling across the definition.
It means it means
transgender girls in a girls bathroom.
Is that what woke means?
I mean,
what does it mean to you, Nikki Haley?
She can't define it.
Neither can Ron DeSantis.
Most Republicans
can't really hate the debate
because it's anti-intellectual,
but it's a part of their cultural war
that they're trying to wage against.
I don't know.
Well, why are you so unsatisfied
with Booker's response?
Because that's what you're saying.
Because, look,
the Republicans
who are running for president
and most Republican voters perceive
a very deep cultural rot
in the United States.
That's in government,
media, corporations,
universities, everywhere they look,
they see this cultural rot.
That's the definition.
And that's
so she hit that note on Woke,
but then she turned around and attacked
Ron DeSantis on Disney
after saying his one
law didn't go far enough.
Then she attacked him on the lawsuit.
She was a little,
although she's not as comfortable
with it.
Yeah, this is where DeSantis is scoring
because he is
the one who has most clearly defined
it and seems to be most clearly
focused on it.
And will not let it go
or be distracted by other matter.
That cultural rot
is also known as diversity.
But you know who's keeping count?
A lot more discourse here, guys.
But the thing is, it's only June is
will have plenty of
we have much more time together. Oh, yes.
Bakari and Scott, thank you both.